it can swallow entire gazelles
turtles and even lions
this is the nile crocodile the most
dangerous crocodile in the world
it normally preys on animals found in
africa but
now it's coming for you
how easy would it be for this crocodile
to swallow you
what secrets lie in the crocodile
stomach
and how would its heart help digest you
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you were swallowed by a crocodile
if you think something like this is
impossible think again
crocodile attacks are more common than
shark attacks
and these attacks are responsible for
nearly 1 000
fatalities a year so what would happen
if you were one of these attacks would
you be able to survive
first let's get to know a little bit
more about this creature who's coming
after you
the nile crocodile is typically found in
africa but has also been seen in florida
in the united states
these crocodiles are incredibly
aggressive and
are responsible for over 300 attacks on
people
every year what might make it so
aggressive
is its size the nile crocodile can grow
up to 6 meters long and weigh up to 550
kilograms
all this combined makes it the most
dangerous crocodile
on earth and now it's coming to swallow
you whole
[Music]
you'd first get attacked by the
crocodile somewhere along a river
and it's likely this would happen
between december
and may since that's the crocodile's
breeding season
as you're walking along the river the
crocodile would stalk you
waiting for the perfect opportunity to
attack
you probably wouldn't even notice the
croc and
even if you did it might be hard to get
away from it as
the nile croc can run up to 18
kilometers per hour on land
and as it caught up to you it would
strike at your leg with
its massive jaw applying 3 500 kilograms
of pressure
this would break your leg preventing you
from getting away
and now the crocodile could drag you
into the river
where it likes to do the rest of its
eating
now that you're in the water with the
crocodile biting into your leg
it would begin to roll you around in the
water this
is it attempting to disorient and drown
you
and at this point you'd be passed out
and now that you're not moving the nile
croc
would swallow your body whole
you would pass through the crocodile's
esophagus and
into its stomach but wait
this is a lot of food and not every
animal would be able to eat something
like this so
how can the crocodile well the crocodile
stomach
is unique that's because these creatures
swallow rocks to help break up their
food
and that's why the crocodile didn't need
to chew you
while you're inside the crocodile
stomach you'd be smushed by
all these rocks and with that your body
would be broken up into smaller chunks
and
rocks aren't the only thing that would
help the croc digest you
inside the crocodile's body is a heart
valve that they control with their
nerves
instead of this valve going to the
crocodile's lungs
it goes to the stomach this allows the
crocodile to produce
10 times more gastric acid than most
other animals
over the course of a week your body
would be getting crushed up by all these
rocks and
you'd be getting dissolved by all the
stomach acid
skin bones hair and all
then the crocodile would poop out your
remains and
go hunting for its next victim so
the next time you're near a swampy river
watch out for crocodiles
if you're not careful they can be pretty
dangerous
but you know what's even more dangerous
than a nile crocodile
terror crocs but we'll leave that story
for another what if